let's say that i run a website that
currently has this off-white color for
its background and i know the mean
amount of time that people spend on my
website let's say it is 20 minutes and
i'm interested in making a change that
will make people spend more time on my
website my idea is to make the
background color of my website yellow
but after making that change how do i
feel good about this actually having the
intended consequence well that's where
significance tests come into play
what i would do is first set up some
hypotheses a null hypothesis and an
alternative hypothesis
the null hypothesis tends to be a
statement that hey your change actually
had no effect there's no news here and
so this would be that your mean is still
equal to 20 minutes
is still equal to 20 minutes after
after the change to yellow in this case
for our background and we would also
have an alternative hypothesis our
alternative hypothesis is actually that
our mean is now greater because of the
change that people are spending more
time on my site so our mean is greater
than 20
minutes
after
after the change
now the next thing we do is we set up a
threshold known as the significance
level and you will see how this comes
into play in a second so your
significance level
significance
level
is usually denoted by the greek letter
alpha and you tend to see significant
levels like 1 100th or five one
hundredths or one tenth or one percent
five percent or ten percent you might
see other ones but we're going to set a
significance level for this particular
case let's just say it's going to be
0.05
and what we're going to now do is we're
going to take a sample of people
visiting this new yellow background
website and we're going to calculate
statistics the sample mean the sample
standard deviation and we're going to
say hey if we assume that the null
hypothesis is true what is the
probability of getting a sample with the
statistics that we get
and if that probability is lower than
our significance level if that
probability is less than 5 hundredths if
it's less than five percent then we
reject the null hypothesis and say that
we have evidence for the alternative
however if the probability of getting
the statistics for that sample are at
the significance level or higher then we
say hey we can't reject the null
hypothesis and we aren't able to have
evidence for the alternative so what we
would then do i will call this step
three
in step three we would take a sample
take
sample
so let's say we take a sample size let's
say we take 100 folks who visit the new
website the yellow background website
and we measure sample statistics we
measure the sample mean here let's say
that the
for that sample the mean is 25
25 minutes
we are also likely to if we don't know
what the actual population standard
deviation is which we typically don't
know we would also calculate the sample
standard deviation
then the next step is we calculate
a p-value and the p-value which stands
for probability value is the probability
of getting a statistic at least this far
away from the mean if we were to assume
that the null hypothesis is true so one
way to think about it it is a
conditional probability it is the
probability
that our sample mean
our sample mean when we take a sample of
size n equals 100 is greater than or
equal to 25
25 minutes
given
given
our null hypothesis
is true
in other videos we've talked about how
to do this if we assume that the
sampling distribution of the sample
means is roughly normal we can use the
sample mean we can use our sample size
we can use our sample standard deviation
perhaps we use a t statistic to figure
out roughly what this probability is
going to be
and then we decide whether we can reject
the null hypothesis so let me call that
step five
so step five there are two situations if
my p-value
if my p-value
if it is less than alpha
then
i reject my null hypothesis
reject
reject my null hypothesis and say that i
have evidence for my alternative
hypothesis
now if we have the other situation
if my p
value
is greater than or equal to in this case
0.05
so if it's greater than or equal to
my
significance level then i cannot reject
the null hypothesis i wouldn't say that
i accept the null hypothesis i would
just say that we do not
do
not
reject
reject the null hypothesis
and so let's say when i do all of these
calculations i get a p-value
which would put me in this scenario
right over here let's say that i get a
p-value
of 0.03
0.03 is indeed less than 0.05
so i would reject the null hypothesis
and say that i have evidence for the
alternative and this should hopefully
make logical sense because what we're
saying is hey look we took a sample and
if we assume the null hypothesis the
probability of getting that sample is
three percent it's three one hundredths
and so since that probability is less
than our probability threshold here
we'll reject it and say we have evidence
for the alternative on the other hand
there might have been a scenario where
we do all of the calculations here and
we figure out a p-value
a p-value that we get is equal to 0.5
which you can interpret as saying that
hey
if we assume the null hypothesis is true
that there's no change due to changing
making the background yellow i would
have a 50 percent chance of getting this
result and in that situation since it's
higher than my significance level i
wouldn't reject the null hypothesis a
world where the null hypothesis is true
and i get this result well you know it's
it seems reasonably likely
and so this is the basis for significant
tests generally and as you will see is
applicable in almost every field you'll
find yourself in now there's one last
point of clarification that i want to
make very very very clear
our p-value the thing that we're using
to decide whether or not we reject the
null hypothesis this is the probability
of getting your sample statistics given
that the null hypothesis is true
sometimes people confuse this and they
say hey is this the probability that the
null hypothesis is true
given the sample
given the sample statistics
that we got and i would say clearly no
that is not the case we are not trying
to gauge the probability that the null
hypothesis is true or not what we are
trying to do is say hey if we assume the
null hypothesis were true what is the
probability that we got the result that
we did for our sample and if that
probability is low if it's below some
threshold that we set ahead of time then
we decide to reject the null hypothesis
and say that we have evidence for the
alternative